The joe rogan experience,
one of this Skype things that this Peter Popoff does,
he also sends you a barley cake from the Bible where it's like,
kind of like that little bread you eat.
And he goes,
ah.
He goes in this commercial,
he goes and we make it with the exact ingredients that they say in the Bible and
Blah,
blah blah.
Well then if you look up Zeke eel four 12 in the Bible,
it says,
and you should eat it as barley cakes and bake it using fuel of human waste,
human way.
So,
so in any way,
you want to bet [inaudible] for 12
okay,
Becky with Dung that cometh out of man in their sight.
Oh,
so he's saying
are cooked with shit.
Oh my God,
thou shalt bake it with Dung and that cometh out of man in their sight
in the,
to study the Bible and Cook Cookie bread with Shit.
Have you ever tried my purple barley cake?
You fucking imagine how dumb people are.
That really hurts my brain.
Do you know what Zeke?
Zeke,
you'll might've been a tripper cause the Zico was also where the first
depictions of Ufos came from.
Here,
let me pull that up.
How do you not read that and just start laughing?
You told me to cook shit cakes.
The Bible says Cook Shit cakes.
That's just one more dumb thing in the Bible.
God down.
I was so tired of people pretending.
That book's awesome.
I'm so tired.
You stop that shit stupid.
Okay,
here.
Here's a,
here's a quote.
And I looked and behold,
a whirlwind came out of the north,
a great cloud and a fire enfolding itself in brightness was about it and out of
the midst thereof as the color of amber out of the midst of the fire.
Okay.
How's audio file?
Hmm?
Somebody putting two points together that don't go together
well,
wait a minute,
hold on.
Listen to this.
Also.
Out of the midst thereof came the likeness of four living creatures and this was
their appearance.
They had the likeness of a man woe.
After in,
everyone had four faces in.
Every one had four wings and their feet were straight and the sole of their feet
was like the soul of a calf's foot and they sparkled like the color of burnished
brass.
What a trippy book.
People like,
oh my God,
it's so real.
I hear God's words when you're saying each things God's speaking to me through
your words,
please read on.
And they had the hands of man under their wings on their four sides and they
had,
and they four had their faces and their ways.
Somebody might have just made all this up and me like an asshole as reading
these fake Bible quotes shitting all over the Bible and the aliens.
But guess what?
I don't care.
I'm not,
I'm not reading any further.
It's,
it seems like if this is,
if this really is the gills,
it says it is.
God dammit.
They could saw nuttiness.
They walked up with their four faces and they said,
why are you guys cooking things in Shit?
And the living creatures ran in,
returned as the appearance of a flash of lightening.
Now as I behold the living creatures,
behold one wheel upon the earth by the living creatures with his four faces.
These guys were tripping hard eating shit cake.
So yeah,
losing their mind.
But you are afraid of aliens though,
right?
Yeah,
my friend.
Does it show a path mapped out in your house?
How to get out of the aliens show up?
No,
that's the rumor.
I heard you have a plan because I know you like to use game plans,
so I figured,
I know,
I know cat ready and I know Jujitsu so the and show up.
I put a triangle choke on him and I also have a cat that ammo.
So I kept that in a Japanese.
Got that now.
So if they come I can slice them apart.
Wow.
Do you keep a sword in your house?
That's pretty gangster.
It's a collection.
You know it's funny.
It's as to to bring any crazy bitches home.
I man,
it's a sword and crazy bitches.
I have this
side of my bed that I always forget is there and I was like almost cut my finger
off all the time.
At the middle.
You should put that in the garage song fuck is wrong.
Cause like big sword slash meat cleaver that it's just
so,
do you really have a fear of aliens or is this just a bullshit rumor?
Cause it,
what didn't you do a countdown show and you did a whole thing talking about how
you being scared of being abducted by aliens.
Yeah,
I'm scared.
I'm scared of a lot of things,
you know?
I'll get,
I'll get into it.
I got,
I kept talking about it right now,
right?
Yeah,
I'm talking about it right now.
How's that one day elegant to come out and make a big thing about it,
but not all right.
I believe had been,
hold on,
hold on.
Yeah.
Have you had an experience with aliens?
No.
No,
no,
no.
I don't believe you.
Okay.
No,
I don't know.
You don't know.
You might have had an experience with it.
I and my manager got to have a heart attack right now.
I would never do or lead you down any path.
It's bad for your career.
Just as you said that it's good to be afraid.
It's also good to be honest about everything.
Even shit.
That sounds crazy.
I love it.
That's the thing.
I'm on this and like,
look,
I'm on s I'm afraid,
but I don't have to tell everything on,
on the lake.
It's true.
You don't,
but you know,
in an alien because you're a smart guy.
Let me tell you,
you're a very smart guy.
You know,
you know how to dig,
dig into people's mind.
And as Martin,
I like you.
I lie.
I hate that about you because he put me on the spot right now.
But he's a very smart guy.
But now I know I gotta I gotta go too deep.
Listen,
if I was on an alien spacecraft and I had sex with an alien,
like I'm assuming you did,
I feel like I would just come out and talk about it.
I don't know why he would hold that back.
Nah,
man.
I mean,
ah,
something happened,
George.
I don't know.
It's either,
it's either I'm crazy or,
or,
uh,
maybe it really happened,
but I,
I hope that I'm crazy.
I don't think you're crazy.
I hope I am.
It could be pre crazy cause he know some people,
some great mine and you know they had,
they had been hallucinating stuff or some people are are,
I'll just say Mandy equity oppressive.
Some people are,
are uh,
OCD.
Some people are dead,
some people are dead and they're still there.
They've been able to actually have great stuff on their life.
And also maybe I'm crazy when I was,
I don't know,
I open well
water in New York,
there's no good water.
You can't drink any of that.
You can't grow fish in any of that.
All that water's polluted with like,
yeah,
you know,
it's the Hudson the way it is just the way it is.
It's fucking animals.
Just throwing glass and shit and Piss and tampons and rubbers and fontes body
fuck fucking dead people from New York,
new the Jersey Cylon on Sundays.
It's like a big day for him.
Like we're going to Jersey on fucking Sunday and they go over it and they fish.
They catch eel,
no gorilla.
Oh what the fuck?
It's just an ideal.
Got Meat on it.
Just might reveal from the fucking hood.
That's why I used to get,
I'm not cancer.
They can suck my dick.
I need to heal from the phone.
I remember we were in Jersey one time and me and Joe on a bus and it's a side,
a UFC event,
and I showed him this pond and I said,
look at cancer.
It was late cancer.
It was cancer at this pond had hadn't move that no movement.
It had like a layer of this green algae,
which really wasn't green.
That's just cancer that you know they,
you know New Jersey,
they've been dumping shit since the 70s since the sixties bro.
That that's never going to be,
that's what's,
what's a,
what's that word of Reco?
RECO bubble.
Reconcilable.
No,
the other word,
when you can't reverse it,
you can never ever a reverse goes that soil and
that soil in New Jersey.
I remember when that,
when they built the metal lands,
I remember how many animals,
all of a sudden I had in my living room because they tore all that down,
that wildlife.
And next thing I was seeing,
I remember one night seen a possum,
the size of a small people fucking treat jumped on a fucking tree.
You saw me,
he walked like a fucking ate those things.
When you call the police in Jersey,
I've got a possum here.
They shoot the fucking thing.
Oh shoot.
Snakes in the lottery.
They shoot the fucking possible cause they play dead.
And then when the cops leave,
they fucking get up and they brushed as you could run over a fucking car with
bicycles and throw names out of
behavioral trait.
They play day fucking ways.
Some that's where playing possum.
Oh,
I seen a fucking possum that looked at me one night at like four in the morning.
I looked at him,
I was like,
what the fuck?
And he jumped on a tree
and I was like,
this is fucking mind boggling.
Okay.